These are the factored forms. Great work for getting at least half of these
right. If you really struggled with these, I would go back and review
factoring. Try and get in some more practice before moving on. If you only
missed one or two, then see if you could find your mistakes by looking at your
factors. If you can't find your mistakes, then continue watching the solution
to see where your reasoning went wrong. The greatest common factor for these
three terms is one. So let's use factoring by grouping to get our two factors.
We want factors of negative 30 that sum to negative 1. The factors are negative
6 and positive 5. Then we can use factoring by grouping to get the factors of
3x plus 1 and 5x minus 2, this is our first numerator. For the denominator, we
want to find factors of negative 20, that's sum deposit of 8. The factors would
be positive 10 and negative 2. We use factoring by grouping to get our
denominator of 2x plus 5 times 2x minus 1, here. Next, we factor this
trinomial. The greatest common factor for each term is one, so we need to find
factors of negative 60 that sum to negative 7. We don't need to factor out a g
c f. These two factors are negative 12 and positive 5. They might have been
tough to find. We use factoring by grouping to get 2 x plus 5 times x minus 6.
And this is what we put in our numerator. For our second denominator, we want
to find factors of negative 30 that sum to positive 13. We use factors by
grouping to get our factors of x plus 3 and 5x minus 2. And now we're done
factoring, and we're ready to simplify.